[Music]
the latest coronavirus surge is filling
many hospitals to or near
capacity and pushing some health care
workers to a breaking point this morning
carter evan shares the stories of two
nurses who are coping
by pouring their personal experiences
into poetry and song
at loma linda university health in
southern california
it's another day grappling with the
virus ted warku is an er trauma nurse
every shift i walk into the hospital
you're going to be confronted by
something
that you're not fully prepared for
you're never fully prepared for somebody
that will lose their life in front of
you
on your next shift and they impact you
i've seen hope
or from the depth of despair i've seen
peace coming out from nowhere
to cope with the emotional toll tad
picks up his guitar
medicine inspiring his music but i can
see
[Music]
almost 2 000 miles away near minneapolis
hospice nurse aaron pomerantz juggles as
many as 19
patients holding their hands as they
died because
covid prevents families from visiting
what's it like being the person
who holds the iphone for that final zoom
i'm there with my mask and my shield on
and i'm holding up the phone
to see their grandma and their mom one
last time
this is not how we say goodbye to to our
loved ones
she processes her experiences through
poetry
over the phone through the camera lens
one last time you see her brown
loving eyes that once filled the room
with sparkle and joy
the hospital where she works recently
her body is ready you are not
it's not fair you say through tears
i agree my tears and breath clouding the
goggles
back in california
[Music]
began performing for the hospital staff
a support group formed to help medical
workers struggling with the pandemic
his music struck a chord with co-workers
when i don't understand why the world is
acting the way it is and when you hear
dad and you hear his music
it just makes you feel like it's gonna
be okay tomorrow's gonna be okay
tell me that it will be all right
so i think as healthcare workers we all
are coming together
and we really understand what each other
is going through
calm and comfortable the words i use to
carefully describe her to you
you let out a sigh of relief during
hospice pomerance often picks up her
camera
and photographs loved ones one of the
great
parts of my job is finding moments
together and capturing those moments
it's been really meaningful for me to
provide that to families
even if it is just a cell phone photo
like this is how your mom's doing i saw
her today
amber midnight lost her husband brian we
felt like she really captured our
essence
and she went out of her way to do it and
i treasure them
i met an old man and i saw him smile
he looked my way said he walked this
smile
he said keep coming don't you turn
astray
it never ever trade your love away
like pomeranz warku incorporates actual
conversations into his lyrics
it takes the effort to walk into that
environment but to find the hope
in these really difficult times it's
hard i actually think it's the most
difficult thing to do to find the hope
but it's in that moment where it's the
most difficult that it's also the most
important
i'll fight with every fiber to find the
hope
knowing that it exists in there because
if it doesn't
we have a much bigger problem finding
hope
and healing reminding patients families
and colleagues
they're not alone for cbs this morning
carter evans
los angeles
some beauty there born out of the
tragedy and gail king's also a big fan
but she's not allowed to talk because we
gotta go to break